This might be a hot take,
but not everything has to include everyone.
Today, the Boy Scouts of America decided to announce their rebrand
and their new name.
They're going to be called Scouting America,
I think is what it's called.
And they did so.
They claim an attempt to be more inclusive.
They've had a lot of issues for a lot of years,
so I'm sure there's a lot of reasons for wanting to rebrand.
But we see this a lot where we see these organizations,
see these things have been around forever,
and they change
because they claim that they're not being inclusive enough.
You see this in Boy Scouting.
You see this with girls and women sport.
Everything needs to include everybody.
The very worst thing you can be is exclusive.
And anything that is exclusive
needs to be dismantled and rebranded and changed.
But what we fail to realize is that everything,
every word, just by having a definition,
is by its nature, excluding everything that is not that thing.
So if you have anything that is for boys,
it is exclusive, right?
Because it's excluding everything that isn't a boy.
If you have anything for women,
it is exclusive because it is excluding everything that is not women.
Boys need spaces for boys,
girls need spaces for girls.
Men need spaces for men,
and women need spaces for women.
Push. And this demand for everything in our society to be inclusive
is actually just watering Down our organizations
and watering down our institutions
and leaving them meaningless and empty.